wait a minute
Warner Brothers those assholes wouldn't
know how to star war if Yoda lightsaber
them in the Batman's do you get the
feeling with this music that you're
watching somebody's fan film or a
Simpsons parody or a piece you don't
want to watch Star the Clone Wars Wars
also this movie supposedly takes place
between episodes two and three of the
prequels which means this movie is stuck
between the taint and butthole with the
Star Wars franchise a galaxy divided
oh no the movie replaced it's scrolling
text with an overeager narrator also
this feels like it needs spinning
newspapers the innocent become victims
and a lawless galaxy I've seen no ships
before I can say with confidence that
those guys probably aren't innocent if
anything they are taking Jedi to the
Sarlacc pit to execute them crime lord
top of a Hudson I spent kidnapped by a
rival bad dog pirates
excuse me one his son are you serious
funny we're only hearing about this guy
just now this warlord reaches out to the
federal government to help him find his
captured son instead of simply taking
matters into his own hands and sending a
bunch of bounty hunters to do it
the Hutt's control the Outer Rim and
will need their space lanes in order to
move our troops Jabba the Hutt is the
Walder Frey of space maybe Walter Frey
is the Java Hood of Westeros by the way
there's a lot of gross stuff happening
also space lanes also the Republic
basically allows a mobster to control
major trade routes in the Outer Rim the
only Jedi we can spare are Skywalker and
Kenobi conveniently those are the very
best and well-known Jedi we have
animators decided to cut out the
middleman and make their spaceships look
just like lego sets if only there was
some sort of way we as Jedi could do
that some sort of method or force that
we could use to communicate to other
Jedi come on guys was it really hard to
get Frank Oz to do Yoda again you got
samuel l.jackson to do Windu of course
all it takes to get stable Jaxon to do
something is by saying I love your work
samuel l.jackson they would never say
anything to disparage you not even in a
sins' video and he'd do it
clones gun is stuck on some sort of
automatic animated blast which
disappears when the camera moves away
from him probably because the animators
got tired of drawing straight blue lines
that were obviously going nowhere so to
be honest I have no idea why they're
fighting right now maybe they explained
it I don't know I'm mostly just pissed
off already that they took everything
about the Star Wars prequels and
presented it with a rankin/bass holiday
special aesthetic our 2d petting why
does this robot thing here need to
rotate its head to shoot doesn't all of
its blaster power
from the same source also stealing robot
designs from syndrome obi-wan who was
defending himself with slow lightsaber
strokes here somehow to flex all the
blaster fire that comes anywhere near
him in a screen full of blaster fire
three top nighttime attack side follow
me
first of all they didn't know the plan
of attack before they got to this point
second of all they have no plan of
attack Anakin and five clones attack the
evil equivalent of Epcot Center well I'm
just praying that Captain EO makes it
out alive he didn't ask for this obi-wan
Anakin and company are clearly outgunned
and outnumbered but they still managed
to defeat this army of droids you see
this shot right here
this shot explains in painful detail why
a whole bunch of robot shooting each
other is boring SH this clone loses his
blaster and resorts to punching the
droid because every little bit helps you
know unthinking droids need a verbal
command to be told to retreat rather
than a simple signal how do you become a
robot captain anyway aren't all these
things made it the same assembly line
and program with the same code you
really think it's a good idea to bring a
padawan learner into all this Anakin has
a point they are in the middle of a
fucking battle you'd make a good teacher
yeah until he murders the entire class
I'm ahsoka Master Yoda sent me he
doesn't often send cats but with all the
wars going on it's hard to send homing
pigeons anymore so he sent me to deliver
the message okay but why they didn't
have any non-irritating adults that
could deliver a message oh great they
don't even know we're in trouble maybe
you can relate a signal through the
cruiser that just dropped me off they
should not need a child to tell them
this no wonder this battle is going so
badly I found a transcript of the
conversation the animators had about
this planet here's an excerpt the planet
looks fine but it doesn't have enough
detail okay fine just draw some fucking
green lines on it or something I don't
know this joint isn't gonna smoke itself
we lost the transmission sir but not
your transmission you're still coming in
fine and it's not on Yoda's end either
because Yoda and Windu will be yakking
it up with this blue static guy five
minutes later I met your service master
Kenobi but I'm afraid I've actually been
assigned to Master Skywalker I see the
Emperor turned off his mute button on
the hologram thing which makes him
visible in my master Skywalker's Padawan
the names ahsoka tano plus ten sins for
ahsoka tano and every word that comes
out of her mouth this character almost
out Jar Jar Jar Jar you're stuck with me
sky guy her calling Anakin sky
induces a level of rage I rarely
experience from a movie for children I
don't even think you're old enough to be
a Padawan but Master Yoda thinks I am
well Master Yoda is about 900 years old
he is clearly becoming senile and losing
his mind also
looks like a cat who's proud of us that
miss the litter box have you thought
about moving that line back captain
this captain doesn't respond with how
old are you if your captain and I'm a
Jedi you are definitely not a Jedi robot
someone has to get to that shield
generator and destroy it why is the
shield generator out in the open why
can't it be underneath the shield I
don't have to think of these things if
Rex and I can engage them here you two
might have a chance to get through their
lines undetected here Ruby knows this is
such bullsh would rather not establish
an actual setting and prefers not to
tell us where obi-wan is pointing they
will march forward under the protection
of their shields until they are right on
top of our cannons then they'll blow
them away why aren't these assholes
moving faster then if the shield is such
hot meanwhile on the monochrome planet
of propeller a guy walks around looking
for the source of yellow that was
rumored to be here by the old man he met
at the people eater tavern only 15
minutes in and movie is about to blow
their hologram budget you're the one
with the experience which I'm looking
forward to learning from Anakin is
inexplicably beginning to like this girl
sneak through the middle then impossible
unless you can turn yourself into a
droid wait are you telling me that the
shield has the weakness of droids
flotation I mean extrication
this bolt this bolt works also this is
what anakin meant about turning
themselves into a droid hiding under a
box it's the same thing we're inside the
shield this movie in my dictionary
differ in the definition of shield I can
tell because my raccoon powers can sense
danger well under a metal box can't take
it anymore I have to stand up maybe the
so called shield should have been made
of this blue material it seems like it's
actually better at shielding things is
she talking about I've definitely seen
running Jedi before I don't live in this
universe things Jedi should always be
able to do but don't obi-wan shows how
great he is by showing how terrible
these droids are obi-wan is allowed to
do this putting not something I like
will Pete I think he means pee position
easily avoidable trip alarms unless
you're this stupid chick that costs
earthquake robots the tectonic cuz this
also why go through all the trouble of
burying landmine droids when you could
just have a group of droids guarding the
shields movie steals the steamboat bill
jr. thing from Buster Keaton and I never
thought I'd ever write a sentence like
that I had everything under control oh
so that's why you said
when have the clones ever cared enough
about each other in battle to call for a
medic fire on those tanks I'm pretty
shocked that the bad guys had no weapon
that could destroy those cannons before
they got there but I'm also shocked I'm
still watching the movie so both of us
are wrong same thing that happened to
fund me did the exact time that you
destroyed the shield and got the upper
hand that's amazing you're reckless
little one you never would have made it
as Obi Wan's padawan maybe this is the
point but are you kidding me I guess
these are the bounty hunters Java set
but all I saw were people in masks so
this reveal isn't nearly as powerful as
Jabba wants us to think 30 seconds of
shit landing pull the wall down on top
of the droids are we really rehashing
the battle we just saw we only have an
hour and a half to get through this and
the movie is telling me about things I
already saw and hate it we should not
keep their lies and powerful Jabba
waiting
he's been there how long two seconds he
demands you bring back the slime who
kidnapped his little punky mother whose
child referring to his son as a punky
muffin make you angry or are you now Guy
Pearson memento because of it discuss
punky mocking the pet name a father has
for his kidnapped son in front of the
father also that father is a warlord
also you need to borrow that warlord
space Rhodes Java is given us only one
planetary rotation to cool your jets
college boy I'm in command here the
battle droids in this movie are
programmed to be this special brand of
hot-headed asshole to keep
eight-year-olds entertained stay close
to me if you can it won't be a problem
Master are they flirting right now how
old is she supposed to be like thirteen
can't rain fire on check there one one
three seven four two six five
it's almost like these droids don't have
CPUs in them like they've got human
brains inside their robot bodies did we
just witness the violent end of an
innocuous comic relief character there
was that supposed to be funny how are
the droids missing this totally out in
the open Walker they even have these
droids hanging upside down on the clip
that should be able to take a head-on
shot at it way to show a kid who's boss
Anakin are you in some sort of orders
not to kill Jedi when you have the
chance are you those type of evil
minions are you saving him for Baltimore
bastard ahsoka I told you to stay close
to me you just took out four droids and
took one of their flying unicycles and
blast it off to the top of the cliff you
even taunted her for not being able to
keep up because you're so goddamn great
and everything so the who you're talking
about
always in time to save your life always
is a strong word given you guys have
only known each other for a few hours
this looks like one of those put on our
monk monasteries that I read about my
studies at the temple apparently at Jedi
school they cover a wide range of topics
for a movie exposition smugglers take
these monasteries over turn them into
their own personal retreats and the
monks just let them murdered corpses
generally can't fight back not a place
for a servant girl deserving girls carry
these is Anakin gonna tell her she's
holding it backwards there sure doc so
do I want to know how that baby even
came into this world is there a hut
mother asexual reproduction hatching or
budding of some kind I have discovered
it is the Jedi who have kidnapped him
this plan seems way too complicated to
blame the Jedi for kidnapping Java son
what would they gain from it with a
known Jabba would come to them for help
after his son was kidnapped also they
can use his space lanes I think this
little guy is sick he's burning up with
a fever because I took a Hutt physiology
class during my Jedi training and
therefore know when they have a fever
I got a problem Henry yeah in this
screenplay haha screenplay yeah I know
anyway how do I make it believable to
Jabba that the Jedi couldn't have his
son I know how Anakin say I hate huts at
the perfect time a spy robot comes out
to find exactly that evidence wow that's
perfect
what do you think the lettuce out of
this dungeon this smells like Count
Dooku to me nope it's just the movie I
assure you we could use a little help
here if you have the time the crux of
every battle scene in this movie is the
Jedi need reinforcements I'm so tired of
seeing Anakin block this blaster fire
can someone shoot more than two lasers
in his direction please there goes
another Wilhelm only 2,500 more to go
before we
the species I suppose you have a plan
relying on a sofa for a plant so her
plan is to have art to do that thing
where he scans the whole building and
finds a way out got it seal the main
gate in old portals let nothing escape
this castle surely Ventress knows that
these droids are awful I trust them to
do anything
Ventris don't know why it took until now
for this movie to clumsily tell us who
that person was it's not like that chick
is Padme sister or something that would
require this to be a big reveal let me
show you how it works
looks like and we even get excited when
the good guys win against these droids
it's like playing the New England
Patriots against a Pop Warner team and
watching Bill Belichick doing a victory
dance when it's a hundred and sixty
eight to zero by the end of the first
quarter and everyone in the Pop Warner
team is dead Master Q the baby Huck does
not know anything about landing
platforms he's a baby and he was
kidnapped and taken here probably in a
bowling ball bag he doesn't understand
anything about the gravity of this
situation or that it would help and whew
also a convenient landing platform with
another ship on it is very very
convenient we get over there
ahsoka I got all excited about a second
platform but had no idea how they'd get
over there might as well have been on
Earth's moon Anakin jumps on the giant
dragonfly when that apparently wasn't
even an option earlier before he was
like so much for going that way somehow
I forgot the dragonfly riding skill he
learned while vacationing on Pandora
right here that dress despite Anakin
giving her an extremely long time to
simply exterminate this dragonfly thing
or anakin himself Ventress is so taken
aback by this she forgets to sit r2d2
who can do this he's at it again
probably should wait to help her she'd
get all mad if she died while you were
helping don't you dad making basically
all the villains robots is a pretty
clever way to make sure your young
heroes can kill indiscriminately with
zero moral repercussions have you
recovered
Jabba's son how do you know to look up
or down if you're transmitting a message
via hologram need I remind you whoever
gains Jabba's favor will control the war
in the outer rim I hope not because
that's the whole point of everything
that's happened so far also this is like
Indiana Jones saying something like need
I remind you if we don't get the Ark of
the Covenant the Nazis will 2/3 into the
movie also it sounds like Dooku could
simply have kidnapped chavez kid then
cut out the part where he framed the
Jedi for and simply brought the kid back
to win Jabba's favor that way it could
have said anybody other than the Jedi
and it would have been a better plan
hey weren't the evil robots about to fly
the ship out of here
when this thing just be ready to go
laughs there's nothing artoo can't
accomplish by sticking his penis in it
but kind of jump what's that
well now I'm impressed Ventress allows
obi-wan to quit now you just kill him
already well get focused because things
just got a lot harder
Anakin says the same words he said to
Padme on the first night they apparently
anakin decided to approach a friendly
ship in an enemy ship without telling
anyone and he expected everyone to
understand that he was a good guy by his
flying style I guess we've premature
celebration that changes our plans the
explosion and numerous deaths yes I
would hope so also this is a perfect
example of the duck tone that permeates
this entire movie it's possible to have
a quipping roguish antihero without
being a blonde dick Obi Park or her
makeup doesn't look evil so much as it
looks like she tried to make a suction
cup over her mouth with a drinking glass
Anakin makes the ship jump into
hyperspace but wasn't ahsoka looking for
medical supplies and his baby Java even
strapped in and isn't r2 just standing
around like a dick wooden hyperspace
cause all three of those people I just
mentioned to crash their bodies into the
windshield when the moon hits your eye
like a flattened representation of
spherical objects that's a shoddy
animation nice Fitbit all that trouble
with javis kid being sick and somehow
this random trooper carries a magical
serum that saves the day they only
promised to rescue your son to win your
trust job despite being a disgusting
larva troll is smarter than this right
Jedi are many things but resorting to
kidnapping their reputation is way more
solid than that right nor - I want the
cannon operational first leave the rear
deflector shields for later Katie do
both he has the magical penis a strong
attack eliminates the need for defense
the best defense is a good offense sure
but I wouldn't act like fields aren't a
great unnecessary idea it's too bad you
decided not to repair the rear deflector
shields I'm sure it'll be fine despite a
massive amount of fire these assholes
couldn't hit this ship even if Anakin
stopped in midair and built another ship
on top of this one weight to the blast
that missed the target just keep
careening through space forever until
they eventually it's something we've
attempted to contact Jabba he won't
accept communication from us and there's
no way in this futuristic world where we
can leave a message or tell him what's
going on intergalactic voice mail won't
be invented until Steve Jobs soul
arrives in the galaxy Jabba the Hutt
an uncle in the old downtown area here
on Coruscant convenient relative on
another planet is even more convenient
than a landing platform with the ship on
it
what is it Kronos 327 movie introduces
us to Jabba's androgynous uncle who
speaks fluent English and maybe the only
english-speaking Hutt in the entire
franchise only because subtitles are
hard walking through the desert with no
water or protection from Toussaint's
maybe that's why I Sokka is that color
Master Yoda has a same old sans cast
long shadows like that lap dancing ah so
many memories what she found out I
helped you kidnap Chavez son and what if
I spelled it out in truly obvious
fashion just so an eavesdropper could
hear me you my friend to take control of
all character introduced with 15 minutes
left in the movie revealed to be the
catalyst of all the film's action I
sense it too baby Hutt can also sense
the dark side of the force
time to split up Ruby decides to become
an episode of scooby-doo in the last 10
minutes
don't touch that whatever you do keep
away from it's gonna be dangerous
these droids have apparently never seen
one of these hologram things before
which in this universe is goddamn
impossible your training has come a long
way it's it's lured complimenting a
young Jedi and their progress as a Jedi
during a lightsaber fight cliche she's
more skillful than you think Anakin has
no reason to believe this also why are
you laughing - ku and it can just took
your only mode of transportation and you
were in the middle of a desert is
anybody home Threepio what is that a
robot it's always working robots the
clones come in blasting and just barely
managed to miss Ziro the Hutt who is
their only way of proving the Jedi
innocent in the kidnapping your timing
was perfect
it wouldn't be Star Wars without some
perfectly timed ex mocking us
I guess we're supposed to be happy that
Java who is a dickhead got his son back
because his son is a collectible that
probably this whole movie was made for
one day you'll make my daughter wear a
slave outfit force exploitation but I'm
not here to talk about that right now
senator you have my undying gratitude
[Music]
I and the Republic who owes you thanks
the Jedi armies will now have the supply
routes to the Outer Rim the story will
almost certainly be referred to
throughout Revenge of the Sith and the
characters of ahsoka Jabba son and
Ventress will all be remembered finally
in this universe by people who don't
watch the cartoon series later
[Music]
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes crime lord top of
a Hudson I spent kidnapped by a rival
band of pirates in the game yell if that
shields gonna be such a problem why
don't we just take it out weird story
Donnie they're like a child it wanders
into the middle of a movie
nonsense general there are numerous
details to be discussed with you soon
yeah there's a dead guy in here captain
what's going on down there
maniacal laugh